if the resistance is violent shoot and
shoot him dead
human rights crisis has deepened Mr
Pamela is he a killer your president no
he's not he would have not won the
presidency if that is not his style
Rodrigo duterte Rose to power in the
Philippines using his image as a tough
guy either you kill me or I will kill
you idiots since he took power in 2016
extrajudicial killings have become
routine and the country has seen a
Crackdown on civil society dozens of
journalists have been killed and
attacked media Outlets silenced and the
situation has only become worse during
the covid-19 pandemic the virus will
pass but can the Philippines ever hold
the spread of impunity let's dig in the
conflict Zone files
[Music]
foreign
to the government's own account more
than 5 600 citizens have been killed by
the police over the last four years
taking into account drug-related
killings carried out by unidentified
Vigilantes the number of victims Rises
to 16 355.
Hitler massacred three million Jews
there's a three million
I'd be happy to slaughter enough
he was in fact elected on the back of a
promise overwhelmingly at that on the
back of a promise to kill wasn't he he
works within the context of the law we
can kill out of self-defense yes but the
claims of self-defense are not so
clear-cut a U.N report from June 2020
pointed to repeatedly recovered guns
bearing the same serial numbers from
different victims in different locations
this fact could indicate guns had been
planted as evidence after the killings
of unarmed victims
victims families are tasked with coming
up with their own evidence of events and
that's very difficult when you have
police who won't provide police reports
of the killing when you have
families who can't afford lawyers
um to gather that evidence or to even
file that evidence
courts are very dependent on witness
testimony and when you don't have
witnesses who are willing to come
forward to testify in cases it becomes
very difficult so families can't find
these witnesses to come forward these
Witnesses themselves are very scared
police are are patrolling neighborhoods
where these people still live and and uh
you know pretty freely as a result of
the thousands of Investigation to know
these killings only one has led to any
convictions
foreign
commissioner is June 2020 Human Rights
Council report on the Philippines
documented a serious lack of due process
in police operations and near total
impunity for the use of lethal Force by
the police and the military
we urge the police to take urgent
measures to prevent the use of excessive
force resulting in loss of lives during
law enforcement operations
we also call on the government and
members of security forces to refrain
from rhetoric that may lead to
violations
and instead make public commitments to
uphold human rights and the rule of law
another troubling trend is the rise in
the use of what's known as red tagging
as a tool of silencing criticism in 2018
the department of adjusted listed 649
people labeled as terrorists among them
were known human rights Defenders and
political activists and the human rights
groups that you hate say as many as
twelve thousand Human Rights group you
know they dispute what they claim what
we've seen is that government critics
human rights Defenders political
activists have been targeted by Red
tagging which means that they are at
more risk of
being killed for instance being
arbitrarily arrested and detained and in
danger of of being subject to to other
types of abuses threats harassment for
instance
in 2018 the United Nation listed the
Philippines among the countries where
activists are subjected to alarming and
shameful levels of harsh appraisals and
intimidation
local human rights groups in the
Philippines have documented 316 killings
of activists and human rights Defenders
since dutere came to power
there is a history of Human Rights
Advocates being red tagged or being
accused of being fronts for the armed
wing of the Communist Party in the
Philippines
in our June 2020 report the High
Commissioner warned that such public
labeling has proved extremely dangerous
and she urged the protection of Human
Rights Defenders journalists and others
at risk
in recent months there have been dozens
of other activists and several
journalists arrested
red tagging is also used against
environmental activists in 2019 the
Philippines was second deadliest country
in the world for people defending the
environment with 43 killings
soon after his election duterte made
clear where he stood on the freedom of
the press
just because you're a journalist you are
not exempt from assassination freedom of
expression cannot help you if you have
done something wrong
we've seen a Crackdown
um on the media and and other critics uh
of the government uh which has um had an
increasingly chilling effect on the
right freedom of expression in the
country
since the Toyota came to power there
have been 171 documented cases of
threats and attacks against the media 18
journalists have been killed
we've seen prominent journalists like
Maria ressa editor of the online
newsletter Outlet raffler being picked
charges of cyber libel charges of tax
evasion which we believe at amnesty are
trumped up charges so politically
motivated charges
and we've also seen the shutdown of a
major media Network avs-cbn another
Outlet which was doing a lot of
investigative reporting and and
um often critical of the government as
well
the United Nation had this description
for what has happened in the Philippines
under President duterte
a heavy-handed focus on countering
National Security threats and illegal
drugs has resulted in serious human
rights violations in the Philippines
Office of the UN Human Rights High
Commissioner June 2020
in 2022 duterte's famous president is
due to end what Legacy will he leave
behind
what I have is an ordinary leadership if
I can lead this nation to minimum
greatness but I would like to promise
you a comfortable life
you're heading towards a dictatorship in
this country no I don't think so because
Mr duterte promised it back in October
2015. no what he said he said it's going
to be a dictatorship it's the police and
the military who will be the backbone at
that time he said about the presidency I
won't do it if you want to place me
there with a solemn pledge to stick to
the rules if you don't want that okay
look for another son of a [ __ ] when he
was a candidate he said if all things
fail
if Congress opposes things that I want
to have it in place then I'll declare a
revolutionary government you must
remember that this is an election and
this particular promise or commitment is
or was factored in so when the people
voted him in office they were saying to
do that
but I have a dictatorship
[Applause]